ils savaient et ils ont laissé faire il
savait qui tu es il s'appelle jean
perron garvan of hémophiles devenus
séropositifs
après avoir reçu du sang contaminé il
est l'un des premiers dans les années 80
a porté plainte
son acharnement permettra la révélation
du plus grand scandale sanitaire de la
fin du xxème siècle l' affaire du sang
contaminé et il y a vingt ans s'ouvrait
le procès le plus attendu celui de trois
ministres mis en examen cinq à quinze
mille personnes ont été contaminées par
le virus du sida à cause d'une
transfusion sanguine avant 1985 et
principalement lors d'une intervention
chirurgicale qu'elle est aujourd'hui
la terrible estimations des spécialistes
c'était il ya trente ans pas encore de
scandale juste un drame des donneurs de
sang infecté ont contaminé une partie de
la chaîne de transfusion mais en 91
une enquête réalisée par une journaliste
de l'événement du jeudi révèle le
scandale des lots contaminés ont été
laissées en circulation en toute
conscience en cause le centre national
de transfusion sanguine le cnts 29 mai
1985 le cnts centre national de la
transfusion sanguine l'écrit noir sur
blanc
selon des calculs statistiques tous nos
produits pour soigner les hémophiles
sont contaminées par le virus du sida
l'état d'alerté déclenchée il y a
urgence et pourtant au cnts
on continue avec les mêmes produits
quatre médecins seront jugés en 92 pour
tromperie ils écoperont de peines de
prison
michel garretta l'ancien directeur du
cnts sera condamné à quatre ans de
prison ferme mais ils rejetteront la
responsabilité sur le gouvernement
écoutez cet ancien directeur général de
la santé l'autorité de tutelle des
centres de transfusion
vous avez l'impression aujourd'hui de
payer un peu pour le gouvernement une
époque je n'ai plus que l'impression
c'est une certitude les cibles edmond
hervé secrétaire d'état à la santé au
moment des faits georgina dufoix
ministre des affaires sociales et
laurent fabius alors premier ministre
ont-ils retarder la mise sur le marché
de produits sanguins chauffer qui
inactive est le virus du sida ont-ils
retardait les tests de dépistage
systématique les anciens ministres se
défendent
georgina dufoix aura cette phrase restée
dans les mémoires
je me sens tout à fait responsable dans
toutes les étapes pour autant je me sens
pas coupable et laurent fabius plaide
l'ignorance le 9 février 1999 s'ouvre
donc le procès de ces trois ministres le
9 mars la cour de justice de la
république innocente
laurent fabius et georgina dufoix seul
le secrétaire d'état et de mon hervé est
condamné mais sera dispensé de peine
on estime à 1350 le nombre des mots
filent contaminées par le vih et à un
millier ceux qui en sont morts
[Musique]